Baby Yoda doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
Baby Yoda doo doo doo doo doo doo
Baby Yoda!
Grandpa Yoda doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
Grampy Yoda doo doo doo doo doo
Grampy Yoda!
Darth
Vader doo doo doo doo doo doo
Darth Vader doo doo doo doo doo doo
Darth Vader!
Forced cHoKiNg doo doo doo doo
FoRcEd ChOkInG doo doo doo doo
fOrCeD cHoKiNg
I always hated that song... -_-
[Film Theorists Theme]
Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Theory
The show that takes the Internet's most adorable meme obsession
and then turns it into cold hard emotionless...
LEARNING
As much as, well, Empire heading up an intergalactic government. It's gotta be a hard job!
It's at the retirement age to 55 and Yoda gets to retire before he can barely string a sentence together backwards
"Do or do not, there is no try."
But if you set the retirement age to like
I don't know... 550! Han Solo's never gonna see his pension
Don't wonder there was a rebellion against these guys!
Now in case you aren't hip with the kids lately or didn't trample your loved ones
And your rush to sign up for Disney+
I'm talking about...
BABY YODA
The tiny, cuddly, wobbly, bubba kins of the new Disney+ show, the Mandalorian.
The baby version of a member of Yoda species who is in, one episode, already the most endearing character in this franchise
Move aside Korg's! Get the boot Ewoks!
Baby Yoda filled the void that you never could
Baby Yoda is like cute ception, but the kicker is that by our standards? He's not even a baby
The Mandalorian depicts him as a 50 year old toddler.
"Their age. That's all you can give me?"
"Yes, they're 50 years old."
By Star Wars standards, that would make baby Yoda part of the Silent Generation
By that, I mean the one that came before the baby boomers
Which, of course in Star Wars, were all the babies that were born right after Alderaan went BOOM!
Okay boomers, there's one less planet in the galaxy
Listen! This topic hits really close to home for me because I currently own a toddler.
You'll hear parents saying stuff
Like I wish they could stay little forever
But half a century of diaper changes is something no one is signing up for
But all those diapers and memes got me thinking, 50 years is a really long time to be a baby
A relatively, helpless baby and I'm saying that as a human the species with the longest adolescence on the planet
So how does this insanely long childhood happen?
And is there any way that 50 years of tummy time could be remotely plausible scientifically?
Well, I started researching, as I do and it turns out that it's not just scientific precedent
But an explanation here for almost everything that we know about the entire Yoda species
That's right! Understanding the biology of baby Yoda
isn't just a fun fact from The Mandalorian or me overthinking a sci-fi franchise
But it's the single key to
understanding the most beloved character in Star Wars
history and why he, Yoda, by the time we get to the main series of movies is pretty much the only
One of his species left
I got to say between this theory
And the last one I did over on Game Theory about Star Wars' force being pretty much
scientifically accurate, which if you haven't watched you absolutely should after this episode
I'm starting to think that George Lucas might secretly be a scientific genius
Almost... let's not give him too much credit
So join me! As I take a look into the evolutionary biology of baby Yoda and finally figure out why they're so cool and also,
why they're practically extinct.
Before we open your biology textbooks to chapter 5, we need to clear the air on one thing.
No, I don't know the actual name of the species Yoda comes from but, you know what?
I'm in good company because George Lucas didn't either.
George Lucas specifically didn't want Yoda's species to have a name
and rarely sanctioned work that revealed information about their Lord
So even though the Yoda's species existed in places like Knights of the Old Republic the video game,
Information about them doesn't appear in anything that's officially canon anymore
So instead of spending this entire episode
Saying the word Yoda and having to clarify between whether I'm talking about Yoda the species or Yoda the individual member of that species
I'll instead be referring to the Yoda species as the Tridactyls
because their extremities have three digits, right?
But bear in mind that's really just a fan-made designation for all the members of the Yoda species that were currently aware of
Which are just three...
Honestly, you got original Yoda
You got Yaddle, from the Phantom Menace who just appears for a couple seconds
and baby Yoda
Whatever his name ends up being from The Mandalorian
So with that bit of housekeeping out of the way and with the very short list of actual known members of the Yoda
species, what do we know about the Tridactyls?
We know that Yoda lived to the ripe old age of 900
in Return of the Jedi, which everyone else was surprised about but he isn't.
Seeming to indicate that it's not really that big of a deal for him.
Baby Yoda, who's just stuck with that name for this episode I guess,
is 50 but functionally he's about at 10 months old, if my kid is any indication
He's nonverbal, but he is capable of walking and getting into trouble
So we know as a Tridactyl, you get 900 years in the galaxy on the high end
but at least the first 50 of them, are spent as a baby
Which I guess leaves like a 100 to make it through high school
Another 200 years of living in your parents basement before finally getting your own apartment
At the tender age of 300 now, because we're working in outer space and in a fictional franchise,
it's worth double-checking when they say that baby
Yoda is 50 years old in the Mandalorian
Does that translate to years as we understand them here on earth and it appears like it does?
according to Wikipedia the Republic's standardized
It's time based on Coruscant which conveniently rotates its son exactly once every 365
course auntie in days which are broken down themselves into
24-hour increments and then minutes that are incredibly close to our own minutes. So when Yoda says that he's 900 years old
It's pretty close to what we think nine hundred years is and the Mandalorian has every reason to be surprised that his 50 year old
Mark was still a baby
So knowing that it's time to talk about the biology
Having such a long development period is more than just an interesting evolutionary quirk
It actually tells us a lot about how try dactyls may have evolved over time mostly because it parallels a lot of our own
human
evolution
You see most animals evolved to shorten the amount of time between birth and reproductive maturity so that they can go on and grow their
Population as fast as possible, but that's not the only successful evolutionary strategy
You may have noticed that us humans have incredibly long and particularly vulnerable childhoods
When a baby giraffe is born, it can stand almost almost
almost
Right away
~its sho kyoot!~
Humans on the other hand not so much it is taking months
If not a year for a baby human to actually get up on its feet
So why do humans the smartest animals on the planet come out so useless?
Well, it turns out that the whole issue comes down to our brains
you see our brainy heads and the fact that they're so fat have changed our entire course of human evolution
Our ancestors who many believe emerged from sub-Saharan Africa
we're among the first species of animals to stop walking around on four legs and start walking upon two
Our brains were big enough that we were able to logic out the idea that it took less energy to walk on two legs
And it minimized our bald skins exposure to the extremely hot ground temperatures in those African deserts as newly bipedal people
Our evolution started favoring other members of our species who could also walk upright good for us natural selection at its finest
But there's always a price to pay for innovation
You see as we evolved to be more and more capable of walking and running around on two legs
our bodies evolved to facilitate that and
compensate for our changed center of gravity primarily doing this by narrowing our hips this in turn helped us to walk upright like
champs and all of a sudden we had a problem that big fat head of ours was
Literally too big to be born sure
We had ourselves a big brain
But now there was nowhere for it to go because our hips were too narrow to accommodate birthing ahead that huge
So human evolution had to change again as the theory goes
we started having babies earlier in their gestational period
earlier at a time when the baby was still tiny and smooshy and helpless which would be pretty darn bad for our survival except for
One thing the heads were still small enough to squeeze up on out of there still a very painful process
but now at least it was doable and then once the baby was on the other end there would be what's known as the
fourth trimester
An extra trimester of development that happens
Outside in the real world where we as parents would have to take care of that helpless newborn because technically it still
Should have been developing in the womb
It just needed to be you know evicted from its home before it was too big to leave its doors
Now, let's take a look at her friendly Yoda.
What features do we see? Well, he's bipedal.
He's small with a disproportionately huge head for his highly evolved brain
He's got a short highly efficient body with diminutive narrow features, including his hips even looking at the basic character model
You can see how in order to procreate the Tridactyls would have to have themselves radically different proportions
You can also see how having a big brain is a HUGE
evolutionary advantage humans are so far at the top of the food chain that we protect other members of the food chain
Tridactyls in the Star Wars universe are the wisest and most powerful force users in the galaxy
But the downside is that they like us are essentially born too early helpless for months. If not, years
Until at least their dad makes them pay rent and their mom stops doing their laundry
This theory continues to hold water
if we look at infancy for humans versus infancy for Tridactyls
In their first two years, human baby brains grow to
75% of their full adult size. We don't know if this is the same for Tridactyls
But we do know that the proportions of human babies paralleled the proportions of baby
Yoda enormous head adorably tiny body besides making babies hilariously top-heavy these proportions
also serve a function in infancy human brains command up to
87 percent
Of the total energy that the body uses at rest
meaning that even while sleeping the body is diverting a massive amount of energy to growing the brain because of this the rest of the
Baby's growth lags behind the head where the brain is.
This according to the expensive tissue hypothesis, we can see that baby
Yoda is an extreme version of this principle with a wildly huge and
merchandisable head and a teeny tiny body, making me think that baby
Yoda is an extremely evolved version of what the human race could look like someday.
The process of evolutionarily along gating the development period is called Neoteny and after humans benefited from it
Surviving when our relatives didn't while evolution didn't stop its role, humans are actually still
experiencing longer development periods
Now than we even did 10,000 years ago
The shape of our faces and heads are continually becoming less like our Neanderthal cousins by becoming flatter less hairy less
oblong again
We share a lot of these same features with Yoda whose small flat faced with an enormous head
But if human evolution continues to make our childhoods longer and longer the question, of course becomes where does it stop?
Well, it stops at Yoda. The problem with a long childhood
Is that a lot can happen when you're tiny and helpless
Eventually, there's an evolutionary tipping point where childhood becomes so long
that it actually leaves the species too vulnerable to survive into adulthood
Tridactyls could very well be the extreme end point of a species like ours.
As The Mandalorian clearly shows,
baby Tridactyls, even 50 year old baby tridactyls aren't capable of taking care of themselves. Sure
They have impressive force powers, but very little control over them
Human children
similarly are pretty darn helpless and it means that we have to do things like baby prove the house and make up all kinds of
Safety rules for kids imagine having to worry about that sort of stuff for fifty or even a hundred years
It becomes extremely hard for the species to get their offspring to a place of self-sufficiency
And that's just the tip of the iceberg natural disasters plagues drone attacks from the Empire
All of those things are gonna be pretty darn hard to avoid but they become a lot easier
To bounce back from if suddenly your species can repopulate quickly
but if all of a sudden you're spending a hundred years or more to reproduce a single generation, I mean
You're just begging for the next Death Star to give you a little zap. Which brings us
to Yoda, we know so little about his history, but what we're able to theorize is pretty darn incredible
He's practically the last of his species because of the evolutionary double-edged sword that he's dealing with on one hand
He's one of the most highly evolved beings in the galaxy
But he's so evolved that his species can no longer survive. They're completely obscure
It's incredibly tragic and no we don't have any of the details about how the Tridactyls were wiped out
But that elongated childhood that extended neoteny to the extremes of 50 plus years of childhood
That is certainly a massive
Contributor as to why so incredibly Star Wars the series often derided as being space fantasy and not science fiction
Turns out to be scientifically plausible yet again. So gotta hand it to you Lucas. I'm pretty stunned know
I've tried to help you out with this and the whole midi-chlorians powering the force thing
But I got to admit still have some quibbles to level at you about the Jedi's recruitment practices now
It'll be coming up pretty soon. We have some bones to pick on that front
Ok friend in the meantime,
if you didn't see the real-life equivalent of midi-chlorians
And how they're actually powering the real-life force in your day-to-day life. Click the video that you see on screen right now
That'll take you to my other science of star wars episode over on Game Theory
looking at midi-chlorians,
Mitochondria, and how we're all just a little bit Jedi
In the meantime, remember that's just a theory,
A FILM THEORY!
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaand
CUT